when I was 18 years old in February of
1989 I entered the US Army intending to
become a combat engineer and so I wound
up going to Fort
leonardwood and I left from here in
Milwaukee actually just blocks from
where I am shooting this where they had
the me station in the federal building
which is um no longer there it's been
moved to other places so I'm going to
tell you the story of my very first day
and maybe a little bit more as well
although probably I'll put off the rest
to some other Saddler stories videos so
the me station was where you would go to
get tested for your physicals for
inprocessing and typically it was your
recruiter who would take you there I was
living in waaa at the time and that's
where my recruiter was at the recruiting
station I don't remember the name of the
guy you know I'm sure he was just some
uh Sergeant or staff sergeant who was
serving that's one way that you um you
know move up in the ranks you work as a
recruiter it's kind of a a job that's
not for everybody because you do have to
lie to people and that's what he did to
me of course you know some of the time
other other times not lying you know for
example they you know will tell you oh
you know you don't have to get this and
writing or that in writing they'll take
care of that when you get to your
regular station if you haven't gotten in
writing well you're not getting it so I
wanted to be you know a ranger that
wasn't going to happen as my drill
sergeants immediately told me but long
story short he drives me downtown and
you know I've already gone through um
the the
asfb and I've got these you know really
high test scores but I want to be a
combat engineer because me and my budes
had this crazy dream remember this is
late 80s right and we're here in the
Midwest so kind of um you know an
isolated area we had this dream that we
were going to all go into the army in
combat arms of various sorts one of my
friends was going to also be a medic and
then we would get out and my friend
uh his uncle had been a mercenary so he
had connections and that's what we were
going to do and that totally crazy idea
and of course I lost touch with those
guys much later but I saw you know Comet
Engineers I was like wow they they blow
things up that looks really cool you
know I'll get to do demolition that'll
be a lot of fun and you also do a lot of
infantry stuff so I don't remember
whether I had my physical like the day
before or the day of but I was told you
know bring bring bring minimal stuff
because the day that that I'm I'm
actually entering the Army bring minimal
stuff because you're going to ship out
tonight for your your station where
you'll do basic training and in the case
of combat engineers basic training
combined with AIT which is where you
learn your your craft so they kind of
interpenetrated each other and basic
training in the Army this a little bit
of a digression back then I have no idea
what it's like now you know you a lot of
shooting and a lot of marching and some
hand toand combat and you do a lot of
cleaning and a lot of physical training
PT and you spend a lot of time learning
about um how to do on the- field medical
things and nuclear biological and
chemical training as well because we
were preparing to fight against the
Soviet Union and their Allied Forces of
Warsaw PCT in Europe most most likely
and and perhaps in other places in the
world as well perhaps you know the
Korean Peninsula but I interestingly I
did have it in my paperwork if I
remember right that I was going to go to
Germany because that's where I wanted to
be so you know that's what was going to
uh come you know down the line but first
you actually have to get in so you go to
the me station and there were a whole
bunch of us there and um they had us all
lining up in one big cold room it was
winter here in Wisconsin things weren't
as insulated back then and it wasn't as
uh warm as it is now due to global
warming as it was as it is now back then
so I remember all of us being there and
then we had to take an oath and that was
that was basically it and then they said
all right wait around we're going to
send you to Fort leonardwood we're going
to put you all on a bus
and you're going to go out there and
then they'll figure out what to do with
you then and so um we waited and waited
and waited and it's getting you know
it's getting dark and then they told us
all right everybody get downstairs and
and we go downstairs and we're kind of
Milling around we're we're you know
standing out in front of the building uh
right across from the uh they called it
a roach motel at the time the the I
think it's the Wisconsin Hotel I don't
know if it's in as bad shape now as it
used to be back then I suspect it's been
rehabilitated but people said it was
pretty nasty there the ones who had to
stay overnight and then a Greyhound bus
pulls up actually a couple Greyhound
buses and they pile us on they said all
right everybody get on right and um I
had no idea how long it would take to
get to Fort leonardwood in Missouri but
I knew it was going to be a you know a
long trip so we s in and I think if if I
remember right they gave us something to
eat but um I don't remember what it was
and uh then we're on the bus and it's
night time and it's dark and some people
are chitchatting with each other you
know where are you from man you know
where are you going to what what are
they going to do with you and uh of
course everybody at that time was you
know a smoker or endured smoke and so
we're smoking our our cigarettes on the
bus and I think we had some sodas or
something like that that we could bring
along and I'm sure we we must have
stopped at a couple places I was half
asleep a lot of the time I I basically
smoked up my my whole pack in part
because you knew that once you got to
basic training they weren't going to let
you smoke and so smoke them while you
got them is you know the refrain and so
we're chugging along you know and most
of the time we're out driving on the
interstate but it's you know it's fairly
dark because we're going through
Countryside you know I I I imagine we
probably went um through Illinois and
then into Missouri maybe we crossed
through part of Iowa I don't really know
the route that we we took but it was a
long long time and we're going along and
all of us are kind of like winding down
trying to get some sleep if we can but
it's it's it's cold it's uncomfortable
there's guys you know all around you
jostling you and there's always some
guys you know talking with each other
arguing with each other one thing I do
remember about this trip though there
was a guy on the bus who um spoke French
and English he was a cajan I don't know
what the hell he was doing up in
Milwaukee but I could barely understand
his English and I could barely
understand his is French I had a hard
time with both of those and nobody else
could really understand him either so
anyway we're chugging along and chugging
along and chugging along and we finally
in the middle of the night get to Fort
leonardwood and you can see the sign
right and the bus pulls up there and
there's some some talk between the bus
driver and the people at the guard poost
and then we roll in and they're driving
around and we're all looking oh wow you
know you can see the barracks and you
can see other sorts of things I wonder
where they're taking us what's going to
happen next so what happened next was
really quite eye openening bus pulls up
in front of a Barracks there's a couple
drill sergeants standing outside in you
know their their jackets their
characteristic hats that you've you've
doubtless seen in movies and then the
the bus stops the door opens and the
yelling starts get off this bus me
maggots get the hell down here they
start just yelling stuff at us we're all
like whoa what the hell's going on we
better do what these people want you
grab your stuff you run off the bus and
we're all kind of Milling around they're
like get in formation get in lines and
so we're trying our best to do that and
it is cold as hell we're standing out
there in the snow and the snow is about
this deep and I'm like you know I
actually had some some you know like a
jacket and a hat on and gloves and stuff
like that because I'd come in from you
know wakaa to Milwaukee and so I'm like
well this is uh this is really something
and uh there's more than one bus too by
the way there's buses that have pulled
up from other places and not everybody's
actually getting off of our bus uh but
we're all out there and I start looking
around and I realized there's some guys
out there in
shorts because they'd come from warmer
places and it's colder in Missouri in
February than it is in Wisconsin I was
like oh it's going to be nice going down
there you know it's going down south
it's going to be nice and warm and
toasty it won't be like where I live no
it was worse because those winds come
down out of Canada across the Plains and
they blow through those Hills and
forests of Missouri onto the the you
know they'll go through Missouri and
into Illinois and all of that and so it
was it was pretty damn cold so they tell
us first all right get any sort of
Contraband you have and we're like
what's Contraband anything that you're
not allowed and of course we don't know
what you're you're allowed or not
allowed and then they start saying
knives uh you know Alcohol Tobacco any
any any of those sorts of stuff and um
you know I I I'd already smoked up all
my cigarettes I didn't have any alcohol
what I did have though that I was a
little bit worried about I I had a
little bottle of cologne uh Royal
Copenhagen that I'd had been given at
Christmas pretty crappy cologne you know
kind of a cloying smell but it was quite
popular back then to give you know
shaving kits that would have uh After
Shave and cologne and like a razor and
soap and stuff like that and so that's
what I'd gotten that year and I brought
it along and I was like do I throw this
out or do I keep it and so I just left
it in my bag but I was worried oh what
if they search us what if they go
through our stuff and they they they
didn't and and eventually I threw it out
later because what the hell are you
going to do with it right uh who do you
have to smell nice for just a bunch of
other other guys who are getting dogged
out every single day so they're yelling
and they're yelling and and some you
know you can look around around you can
see like everybody's eyes are buling out
and some guys are just standing there
shivering and we must have been out
there in the cold in the snow for a good
you know 5 10 minutes lined up in these
crappy rows that are kind of you know
they're not real military formation
stuff and they're then they're like all
right get the hell inside so they send
us all inside and they're also like you
know making fun of the guys who who have
short sleeve shirts on or or shorts on
who don't have proper clothes they're
like what did you think was going to
happen and so we get inside and um the
next thing that happens is they start
like you know figuring out who's who and
asking us um you know what's your name
and and all that and they start putting
us into groups you're in you're in this
uh squad or platoon rather of this
company it's all one company and you're
in this this uh one you're in this one
you're in this one there are three as I
remember and each one had a couple drill
sergeants assigned to it and we had
Sergeant Henry who had to find out later
on and
um uh oh I'm I'm blanking on his name
but he was a guy who' been in Korea and
we actually got some of the good s and
and staff sergeant Cruz was in charge of
it uh we didn't get Sergeant hup who was
kind of a jerk that actually Sergeant
Henry called him out on or some of the
other sergeants and then the very next
thing that they did is all right sto
your gear over there so we put all our
our stuff
down and those of you who have warm
weather stuff we've got a job for you so
this is before we get to like find a
bunk and go to sleep or anything like
that we need to shovel all this snow out
of the yard and so it's the middle of
the night again probably like 2: or 3 in
the morning
and we're out there in the middle of the
cold and I'm like oh man I'm glad I got
my boots and my you know gloves and my
hat and a good warm coat some of these
poor bastards don't have anything and uh
they give us a bunch of snow shovels and
here's where I get to see another one of
those cultural things so of course
growing up here in the Midwest I shovel
the snow a lot it's just something that
you do all winter long especially if
you're a kid especially if you're a boy
because it's one of those tasks that
falls upon you and you know hopefully
you got a dad who's got you know a
snowplow or a snow blower so you don't
have to do all of it but you know since
my dad died when I was uh 11 I was the
man of the house I'd have to shovel the
driveway and I'd actually make money
going to shovel other people's stuff so
I get out there and I'm just doing the
normal sort of
shoveling some of the people had never
seen a snow shovel before and one of the
funniest things that I saw
only funny for a minute I saw somebody
from somewhere in the South take the
snow shovel and plant it into the snow
as if it was a regular shovel a spade
and then step on it as if they were
digging with it well you can ex you can
sort of predict what happened it was a
metal uh snow shovel and it collapsed
and folded up and now the drill
sergeants were pissed because now you're
destroying Army property and frankly I
think it was all kind of a show they
were just looking for anything that they
could use as material for chewing us out
and you know making an example out of
somebody if it wasn't that it would have
been something else probably this had
happened many times whoever that guy was
and I I don't remember I just remember
him being skinny and scared and you know
sort of like withering as they were
shouting at him about how he was going
to be charged for Wrecking Army property
that had been placed under his control
you know and I was like oh man I'm glad
I'm not that guy you know and we're all
kind of watching giving side eye as you
say and then they sent him inside so I
don't think anything actually happened
to him but we were all like oh these
people mean business you know and so it
was a way of trying to impress things on
us and we got the yard cleared those of
us who are from you know warm climates
um you know interestingly on the bus
there were guys from like Upper Michigan
so the bus had clearly like come down to
Milwaukee from some other places that
were even more snowy and cold then we
all go into the barracks and it feels
actually kind of nice cuz the barracks
are heated not well but sure as hell
better than being outside in the wind
and cold and snow and they're like all
right get in the bar buks you know and
and you know we're like well which one I
don't care you just find a spot and be
in it so we get in the bunks and I think
there were blankets I don't think there
were any sheets or anything there were
um you know just this just the mattress
and uh uh pillows and by now we're like
frazzled we're tired we've been up you
know half the night we just did about a
physical activity we're all ready to to
crash and that's what we did until we
get woken up early the next morning on
you know Army time and they told us to
fall out we're still in civilian cloes
at that time and the very first thing
that they did is form us up into
formations outside of the barracks again
it's cold but they they' managed to get
you know some of the guys who are
inappropriately dressed for the cold
some some gear and because they must
have been anticipating it and they
marched us off to the mes Hall which was
you know I don't know maybe half a mile
from our barracks and you know we go
through the line and get ourselves some
some breakfast never enough they never
gave us enough food uh for the sort of
things that we were going through but it
was you know nice anyway some coffee to
heat up and then they took us off the
very next uh two things that we did that
morning and this is where I'll end the
story I don't want to go on too long
with this was uh go to the
barber and you paid to get a haircut and
your haircut you could ask what for
whatever you wanted but you were getting
the same haircut as everybody else you
were getting it completely shaved off
and it was interesting when you did that
there were some people who had some
really funny looking heads and there
were some people who had massive Scar
Tissue all over their head there was one
guy in particular who was an Alaskan
native and his name was Private boots I
I got to be friends with him over time
he was in uh my platoon although not my
squad and when he got his head shaved
there were long scars all over his head
and we're like wow man what happened to
you and he said oh my older brothers
they like to hit me with the nunchucks
and we're like gez that is Hardcore you
you know you're lucky you didn't get
brain damage or maybe it did you know so
they shaved our heads and then the next
thing that they did was take us to
supply where we got our gear we got
boots issued to us we got all of our um
shirts and undershirts and jacket and a
hat and gloves various kinds of gloves
pants uh socks underwear all of it uh
you know either wool or something like
that in camouflage or olive drab green
and all of us got the same issue some of
it I I I mean I looked out everything
that I had fit there were some guys who
the stuff didn't fit right or the boots
that they got unfortunately private
boots actually got some bad boots there
was a little bit of irony there and they
almost rotted off of his feet but we got
all this stuff and then the um the drill
sergeants took us back to the uh the
barracks and they're like you're
cleaning these barracks right the one
thing that I'll close on that I do
remember and I don't remember exactly
which day this was whether it was the
first day or a little bit later
on was you know we were we were able to
get our hands on um shoe polish kiwi
shoe polish in little tins and we're
supposed to make our boots look decent
right now I had no idea how you shine
boots or anything like that but there
were some people there who who knew
about that uh you know older guys in our
platoon and I remember um one of them um
giving me a little bit of advice so
you've you've heard of spit shining
probably right spit shining we think of
it as like this way of taking your your
boots and you know you rub the Polish in
and smooth it out and maybe you use some
spit and it makes it really nice and
shiny right which is what the drill
sergeants like so you you look
good I actually thought you use spit so
I'm you know putting the Polish on and
shining it up and spitting on it and
stuff like that and this this older guy
and when I say older guy he was probably
I don't know 28 30 or something like
that older black guy uh he's like oh son
spit shining don't actually use spit
that's just a a an expression use water
for that let me show you how to do that
and so he got down and he you know he's
like okay so here's here's how you can
do it and I said well I mean why
couldn't you spit right spit is
basically water and he says well you
have a tendency if you do this long
enough to run out of spit and I was like
well there you go and that was I don't
remember seeing him afterwards I think
maybe he went to a different unit or
something like that uh but that was my
induction into the US Army everything
was pandemonium confusion and then a lot
of waiting around which was in a certain
respect a good preparation for the
things that would
follow